qui est l'interrogateur alice racines
deux autres fidèles de la mosquée sont
en garde à vue vous serez des comptes à
rendre à l'amérique prochainement de
prisonniers vient de donner le feu vert
à une attaque contre une cible
américaine au royaume uni dis moi quelle
est la sienne je voulais seulement livré
un message pour lui fait tout c'est
important seulement ma vie privée mais
si ce n'est pas une ligne sécurisée
on veut vous confier une mission
importante à l'ombre un débrief d'un
prisonnier sur mon équipe déjà quoi tu
comprends pas qu'on n'a pas informé
l'agent de long alors on a été infiltrée
quel genre de bordel à londres fabienne
impliquer la cia et une attaque
terroriste
on a besoin de toi en première ligne en
danger quelqu'un me traquent
t'as pas tout ramener à disposition
on pensait qu'on la contrôler
laissons le passé derrière nous où il
deviendra un obstacle quand il faudra
agir
antilles seront armés vous aurez 5
minutes
dans un autre monde on serait pas là